>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Marisa Bellack: I'm here today
to introduce Michael Hiltzik.
A Pulitzer Prize winning
LA Times columnist
and the author of six books.
While the session was
catalogued under science,
Michael is hardly just
a science writer.
His current LA Times
column focuses on business.
His Pulitzer in 1999
was for reporting
on corruption in the music industry.
He has been a financial
and political writer
and investigative reporter, a
technology writer and editor,
a foreign correspondent
in Africa and in Russia.
His book topics have included
a murder in Kenya, Xerox PARC,
Social Security, the New
Deal and the Hoover Dam.
In other words, he's written
about pretty much everything.
So perhaps I shouldn't have been too
surprise to come across this gem,
written by Michael for the
LA Times in 1988, "Of course,
no one would claim that Trump has
ever been weak on self promotion.
Since 1980, he has been
New York's most visible
and extravagant real estate
man, plastering his name
over Manhattan Island like the
label on a pair of designer jeans."
Michael continues "He even
maneuvered himself in a brief spot
in the national political
limelight by journeying
up to New Hampshire late last
year to give a speech on,
of all things, foreign policy."
When Michael ask him about that trip
and possible presidential
aspirations, Trump replies "I went
up to New Hampshire and
you know what happened?
We had the biggest
reception of anybody."
But Michael concludes in the piece,
sometimes his incessant overflow
of self promotion, extravagance
and high pervaly runs
a little thin, 1988.
Michael's latest book is
"Big Science: Ernest Lawrence
and the Invention That Launched
the Military-Industrial Complex."
It's partly a biography of Lawrence
who won a Noble Prize in 1939
for his invention of the cyclotron
and his lab played central role
in developing the atom
and hydrogen bombs.
It's also about a shift in science
from a pursuit of individuals
with one or two research assistance,
to an enterprise involving armies
of researchers and
billions of dollars.
Before we dive into our
discussion, I'm supposed to mention
that the Library of Congress
has been the festival's host
for the past 16 years.
I want to thank Co-Chairman
David Rubenstein
and the many national
book festivals sponsors
who made this possible in 2016.
You can support the
festival with the donation
by checking the information in your
programs and there will be questions
after the talk and please note that
if you ask a question we record it
for the Library Congress' records.
And now please help me
welcome, Michael Hiltzik.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Hiltzik: Thank you
Marisa for that introduction.
I should tell you that I had almost
forgotten about that piece I wrote
about Donald Trump when I was the
New York Financial Correspondent
for the LA Times until
somebody Tweeted it
at me just a few weeks ago.
And I went back and I pulled it up
and I said "Yeah, I did write that.
That's right, now I remember."
Anyway, thanks to all of you for
joining me this afternoon to talk
about science and physics
and the atom bomb
and how that's all applied together
in history and I should also say--
give my thanks to the Library
of Congress for hosting me here.
It's one of the great institutions
in Washington and a place
where I research now free books
including this one that we're going
to be talking about today.
Anyway, I think talking about
the origins of big science,
that's the capital intensive
became interdisciplinary scientific
research that's today's
prevailing paradigm of science.
I think it's especially
appropriate these days,
because basic scientific research
is under political attack today
in this country as never before or
at least not since medieval times.
In part because it
challenges by its nature,
it challenges embedded
interest especially today,
the fossil fuel industry.
And what we tend to see is that
scientific revolutions tend
to foment economic revolutions,
I think that's really what's
behind a lot of the pushback
that we're seeing against
basic research in Congress.
So it behooves us I think to go
back to the origins of this paradigm
of research and draw us some
lessons from its history for today.
So I'm going to start by outlining
the background of Ernest Lawrence,
a central figure of my book.
A man who changed science in
ways that still resonate today
and will continue to do
so well into the future.
So who was Ernest Orlando Lawrence?
Well the short answer is
that during his lifetime,
he was the most famous native
born scientist in America.
Thank you.
In 1937, he appeared on the cover
of Time Magazine when it was
that on purpose validation of
international celebrity during
that prehistoric era, we
think of as the era of print.
And here's that cover.
You can see it stated November
1st, 1937 over the caption
"He Creates and Destroys."
And that was true.
He had created a new particle
accelerator, the cyclotron.
The most efficient and powerful
atom smasher of its time
and he was using it to
destroy atomic nuclei
as a way to study them.
The invention of the cyclotron
was only the launch path
for Lawrence's lifelong
fame and influence.
He would go on to play a
crucial role in the development
of the atomic bomb
and the hydrogen bomb.
And we'll be talking a little
bit later about how to think
about those programs since we've
just passed the 71st anniversaries
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
just about six weeks ago.
But Lawrence's overarching
legacy was
that he created this new paradigm
of science that still prevails today
and big science is all around us.
High level research funded by the
NIH, the National Science Foundation
which received nearly
$40 billion a year
and government appropriations,
well that's big science.
Masses effort to put a man on
the moon and to send probes
into the farthest reaches of the
solar system, that's big science.
The human genome project was a $3
billion exercise in big science
that launched not only new fields
of study, but new industries.
Solving climate change will be
impossible without big science.
The Large Hadron Collider,
which discovered
that illusive subatomic particle,
the Higgs Boson in 2012, well,
that's the latest iteration
of the first cyclotron
that Ernest Lawrence invented
more than eight decades ago.
That first cyclotron cost less
than a $100 in materials and is fit
in the palm of this hand.
It's offspring today, it
occupies a tunnel 17 miles
in circumference buried under
the French in Swiss countrysides
and it cost $9 billion, and
the cost is still rising.
In fact, here's an illustration
of the cyclotron's phenology.
And one of Lawrence's very first
devices is there on the left.
It's a small container.
It's lathered with red sealing wax
to keep the vacuum
inside that round unit.
In the middle is the 37-inch
cyclotron which was one of the first
that he built that achieved
significant energies.
And then on the right, that's
the Large Hadron Collider.
And for perspective, I think
there's a human being in the guts
of the Large Hadron Collider.
And you can see the
difference on scale.
And here's one of Lawrence's
assistants
on the 37-inch in the late 1930s.
So that's quite an
evolution of a technology
over a period of about 80 years.
You may not recognize a family
resemblance but it's there.
The Large Hadron Collider comprises
about six advance cyclotron's
and other accelerated technologies.
Yet for all that, one central theme
of my book is that this paradigm
that Lawrence pioneered
raises as many questions
about human kind search for
knowledge as an answers.
One of the most important
aspects of big science
that we're still grappling
with is that it gives scientist
and society access to forces
of truly distractive power,
forces that we found
very hard and we hope
in the long run not
impossible to control.
Among the first people to warn
of the implications was
Lawrence's own colleague
on the Manhattan project,
James Franck, a German
and a great physicist who two
months before the first atomic bomb
detonated over Japan in August 1945,
was observing that the
age was already passed,
in which as he put it "Scientists
can disclaim responsibility
for the use to which mankind
has put their discoveries."
And the reason he said was that what
big science had brought about was
"Fraught with infinitely greater
dangers than all the inventions
of the past put together."
And we need to talk not merely
about what we do with the knowledge.
Big science brings us but the
resources we spend on that quest.
Lawrence's legacy challenges
us to think about that.
How to way the monumental effort,
it might take to put a man on Mars
or discover the next fundamental
particle, against the imperative
to fight cancer or pay for
drugs against hepatitis
or multiple sclerosis
for every sufferer
or to end poverty and hunger.
So, all these I think fact is
into what makes Ernest Lawrence
and his work such an
intriguing subject for us today.
He was a small town boy,
born in 1901 in Canton,
South Dakota to a first generation
Norwegian-American family.
So it could be said that he
grew up with the 20th Century.
Like many of his friends, he was
a thinker, fascinated in his case
by radio gear and we could see the
qualities that made him a success
in later life even in boyhood.
Comfortable with technology
and machinery,
I'm assuming curious
and bored with idleness.
Well those qualities came to
fruition in 1929 with the invention
that made his reputation.
Lawrence had been recruited to join
the faculty at Berkeley at a time
when physics itself
was at the crossroads.
The deporting generation,
scientist like Ernest Rutherford
and Marie Curie had been
probing the atomic nucleus
with the tools that
nature gave them.
The emissions of alpha rays
from radioactive minerals
like radium husbanded
by the thimble form.
With those small science tools
that generation had figured
out the structure of the atom
and they had discovered x-rays,
radioactivity and the neutron.
But they'd gone about as much as
they could with nature's gift alone.
To go further they recognize,
science would need probes
of higher energies to delve
deeper into the nucleus
and this could only be achieved
by applying human ingenuity.
It was Rutherford who threw down the
challenge for the next generation,
calling for an apparatus that could
deliver 10 million electron volts,
yet as he said be safely
accommodated in a medium size room.
Well, scientist all over the world
took up Rutherford's challenge,
but what they discovered right
of was that, if you try to apply
or load an apparatus with 10 million
volts, what happens is you blow
up the apparatus so they ended up
with laboratory field with shards
of glass and metal, think about
trying to fire a mortar shell
out of a canon with
a cardboard barrel.
Well, one night in Berkeley,
Lawrence had a brain storm,
what if you don't apply the voltage
to the apparatus but directly
onto the projectile that
you're trying to use?
If you start with the proton
say with the 100 volts,
and give it a 100 volt jolt, now
you've got a proton with energy
of 200 volts, another jolt
and 300 and so on and so on.
But if you do it to a proton
traveling in a straight line say
through a linear accelerator, it
would have to be more than a mile
in length to get to your
particle up to the desired energy,
so it's not exactly fitting and
rested for it's comfortable room.
Well, so now comes the second
part of Ernest brainstorm.
He understands that
a particle crossing
through a magnetic field
will follow a curve path.
So if he applies the magnetic
field to this particle,
he can bend his proton
into a circle,
allowing it to get repeated jolts
from just a single electrode
and reducing the need to
synchronize the electrode's charge
and that's the essence
of the cyclotron,
reduce to its simplest terms.
After enough revolutions,
you've got a particle
that now carries a million volts,
10 million, even a 100 million
and all you have to do is aim
it at a target and let it rip.
The possibilities are limitless and
it all can fit in a medium size room
or at least the first
cyclotrons could.
And here's a schematic of
that principle as it appeared
in Lawrence's patent
application for the accelerator.
You can see at the center here,
this is where a charged particle
was introduced to this vacuum tank.
It spirals through the magnetic
field and at each of these gaps,
it gets a jolt of energy
until it has enough energy
to reach the very edge of the
tank where it can be directed
through another magnetic field out
and toward the target
for bombardment.
Well, Lawrence knows
he's on to something.
The very next day, he's seen
bounding across the Berkeley campus,
but in the holing friends and
colleagues and declaring I'm going
to be famous, and so he was.
Over the next decade, Lawrence's
team, using the cyclotron
to bombard nuclei, discovered
scores of new isotopes including
for example carbon 14, which we
know of for its use in carbon dating
and for other biological
investigations.
Other isotopes became the
foundation of the new science
of nuclear medicine and
the sources of new cures
and there were new elements to be
discovered heavier than uranium,
which has not been seen
in the natural state,
like element 94 plutonium.
Every discovery made by the
cyclotron opened new business
and raise new questions
which hadn't--
and Lawrence responded by designing
new cyclotrons, each one bigger
and more powerful and more
expensive than the last.
Big science took shape rapidly.
In my book, I quote the
physicist Maurice Goldhaber,
who's career expand the transition
from small science to big science
and he recalled as he
put it that the first man
to disintegrate a nucleus
was Ernest Rutherford
and he could hold the
apparatus in his lap.
Then he said "I remember the
picture of all the scientist sitting
in the cyclotron's lap and that
gives you an idea of the change."
And yes, here's Ernest
Rutherford in his lab,
perhaps not holding his
apparatus in his lab,
but you can see it all arrange
on a rather cluttered
laboratory table next to him.
And here's that picture of the
cyclotron that Goldhaber remembers.
Twenty seven scientist of Lawrence's
radiation lab in Berkeley sitting
in inside the magnet of
their new 60-inch cyclotron.
Remarkably, there are three
Nobel Laureates in this picture.
Let's see there is Luis
Alvarez, right here.
Ed McMillan is over here.
I think that's-- I've got McMillan
who was not only Lawrence's
successor as head of his lab
but also his brother
in law and, of course,
Ernest Lawrence is right here in
the middle and one more scientist
who perhaps stands as the
most accomplished physicist,
never to get the Nobel Prize
and that's J. Robert
Oppenheimer who was right up here.
Well, in 1939, Lawrence won the
Nobel Prize for the cyclotron
and what was really
notable about the award was
that for the first time, the
Nobel committee recognized
that the technique of scientific
investigation had become equally
important as-- or perhaps even
more important than theory alone.
And Lawrence demonstrated not merely
inspired scientific technique,
but a genius for scientific
management.
He showed that when you needed
to raise millions of dollars
to build your apparatus,
you had to show the genius
of an entrepreneur,
a general, a CEO.
You had to find ways to raise
money from university presidents,
foundation boards, industrial
executives and government officials
and for scientist,
this was a new religion
and Ernest Lawrence was to profit.
Well, the 1939 Nobels were the last
to be awarded until the war clouds
over Europe began to
dissipate four years later
and that brings us I
think to the central event
in Ernest Lawrence's career.
The Manhattan project will
validate the big science paradigm.
The atomic bomb could
never have been invented
by a solitary physicist working
in his solitary lab using
hand made equipment.
It required an investment
of billions of dollars,
armies of scientist and technicians.
Laboratories build on
an industrial scale.
The Manhattan project was the
first great big science program
and it proved how powerful
an approach this could be
when it brought together a
large team, in that case more
than 10,000 scientists
pursuing a shared goal.
Now, many of, you know, doubt know
at least the outlines of the making
of the atomic bomb,
the efforts starting
with Albert Einstein's famous
letter to Franklin Roosevelt
in August 1939, actually the letter
written by the physicist Leo Szilard
and signed by Albert Einstein.
Observing that the recent
discovery of nuclear fission implied
that bombs could be constructed
from fissionable uranium and warning
that Nazi Germany might already
be working on the problem.
The US government swung into
action creating a high level
of uranium committee to
investigate the possibility.
But almost immediately, the
effort became bogged down
and bureaucracy and inertia.
By mid 1941, the two men responsible
from marshaling America's
scientific manpower and resources
for the coming war, Vannevar
Bush of the Carnegie Institution
and James Conant of
Harvard were on the verge
of cancelling the uranium
bomb project altogether.
And the reasons were understandable.
Physicists in America
haven't made the case
that a bomb could be developed in
time to help win the coming war.
And if that was so, then
every dime spent on a project
like that would be a dime wasted
because it would be diverted
from the effort necessary
to win the war.
But then it fell to Lawrence himself
to interpose his personal reputation
in front of the young men, convinced
that cancellation would be a
short sided and dangerous step,
he demanded a face-to-face
meeting with Conant.
And for the first time, James
Conant heard a physicist
of undisputed stature explain not
only that the bomb was feasible
in the short term,
but it was urgent.
The opinion of the physics
community, Lawrence explained,
especially among those who had
fled Germany and Austria and come
to the US and the UK was that the
scientists who had stayed behind
in the Third Reich, people
like Werner Heinsenberg were
intellectually more than capable
of designing efficient
bomb themselves.
And as Lawrence told Conant, if the
Nazi succeed first, they will have
in their hands the
control of the world.
Well Conant listened and
he was sort of convinced
but one thing still bothering him.
"If only you scientist are so
sure that a bomb is feasible
and necessary", he said, "How
come none of you has volunteered
to step ahead and take
over the building of it."
Ernest he said, "Are you ready
to devote the next few years
of your life for getting
these bombs made?"
While Lawrence sort of swallowed
hard and he said, well "Jim,
if you tell me this is
my job, I will do it."
And that right there that
saved the atomic bomb program
and what may be the single
most important meeting
of the nuclear age, with Ernest
Lawrence's reputation behind it
and its personal commitment,
what was soon up the Manhattan
project would never again be
in doubt.
Now, I want to show you
one more photograph,
a very famous historical artifact.
This picture was taken in Lawrence's
office in LeConte Hall in 1940
at Berkeley and it
shows the brain trust
of American science
just before the war.
From the left, there's
Lawrence and then next to him,
Arthur Holly Compton another Nobel
Laureate and the future transfer
of Washington University
in Saint Louis.
Vannevar Bush is next to him.
There in front is Conant, just
behind him is Carl Compton,
Arthur's brother and then the
president of MIT and they're
over on the right, a mysterious
figure named Alfred Loomis
who had used the millions he
had made as a Wall Street trader
to build a private physics lab at
his state in Tuxedo Park, New York,
from which he cultivated and funded
many distinguished young physicist
including Lawrence
and who is functioning
as a key behind the scenes adviser
to Bush and Conant during the war.
Now these gentlemen had come
to Berkeley as a delegation
from the Rockefeller Foundation
because Lawrence had sought a
huge grant from the foundation
to build his biggest cyclotron yet
and he got it, $1.5 million one
of the largest grants the
foundation had ever made
to a single researcher.
But what's especially remarkable and
important about this photograph is
that this exact group would come
together a year later to act
as a scientific supervisors
of the Manhattan project.
Well over the following four years,
Lawrence would play a
paramount role in that program.
He converted his new
cyclotron into an invention
to enrich natural uranium
to bomb grade
by concentrating its
fissionable isotope U-235.
He designed and supervised a
construction of the industrial plant
to manufacture the enriched
product in a rural district
in Tennessee known as Oak Ridge.
That plant would produce every
atom of the uranium for the bomb
that was dropped at Hiroshima.
He gave one of his young
associates, the chemist,
Glenn Seaborg priority time on
its other cyclotrons at Berkeley
to pursue the isolation
of plutonium,
which would become the core of
the bomb that destroyed Nagasaki.
And when General Leslie Groves, the
head of the project came around,
looking for someone to head up
the actual designing of the bomb
at the lab that became Los Alamos,
Lawrence nominated his close friend
and Berkeley colleague, Robert
Oppenheimer, and got him the job.
Now, all that being said, what
about the moral implications
of this work not only
Lawrence's role
but big science's role in the war?
And, you know, the study of
history is an exercised in looking
at advance through the eyes
of the people who live them
but also applying the perspective
of the years or the decades.
These exercises especially
complicated with nuclear weapons
because we're so familiar with
the consequences of this work.
We know the toll in lives
and suffering from Hiroshima
and Nagasaki, we know the
horrific disfigurements
and long term illnesses of the
civilian residence of those cities,
unlike anything experienced
by any other survivors
of warfare in history.
We know the cloud that civilization
has lived under for 70 years
because of the decision in the 1940s
to unleash the distractive
capacity of the nucleus.
And we know that the Nazis never
actually did have an atomic bomb
program because the scientists who
stayed behind got the physics wrong
and concluded it could
never be built.
But, of course, the allies didn't
know that until the war was over.
Now Germany surrendered in 1945
changed the calculus of this work
but not the momentum of the effort.
But by then, the bombs
were nearly complete.
The impulse to use them was still
strong, to bring a quick end
to the war and the final
debate among scientist
and political leaders
before Hiroshima was
over whether dropping the bombs
on the unsuspecting
Japanese was truly necessary
or whether a demonstration say
over an unpopulated island would
deliver a sufficiently compelling
and grim message to
the Japanese regime.
The record tells us that the last
hold out against dropping the bombs
on civilians was Lawrence himself,
but that eventually he too
acknowledged that the risk of it
that and thus a demonstration that
wouldn't work was too great and he
and Oppenheimer together signed
the manifesto that was sent
in Washington, endorsing
the dropping of the bomb.
Now many of the big scientists
who developed the atom bomb
including Oppenheimer would soon
reconsider their role.
Many would work to promote the
cause of international patrol
over nuclear technology, recognizing
that what big science had unleashed
could be managed safely only
through a new conception of
geopolitics and diplomacy.
Many others would work
to develop nuclear power
and other peaceful
technologies, perhaps in the hopes
of expiating the moral
qualms that Hiroshima
and Nagasaki had brought them to.
Well, Ernest Lawrence
was not among them.
Interest fiction was
not his strong suit
and when he's old friend
Robert Oppenheimer declared
that through the atomic bomb,
physicists had come to no seen,
he responded rather
petulantly that nothing
about his work had
caused him to no seen.
And that was still
true after the war,
when he became the nation's
leading scientific promoter
of the hydrogen bomb, a weapon that
many of his own colleagues viewed
as nothing but a genocidal device
and that even the pentagon
acknowledge could never be used
in a military campaign but
only as a psychological threat.
But because Ernest died in 1958,
we don't know what he would've made
of the nuclear world big
science helped create.
His widow, Molly, thought
he would've been a cast
at nuclear proliferation.
In the late 1980s in fact, she
was so appalled at the role
in the arms race played
by Lawrence's own lab
that she petitioned Congress to take
her husband's name off the facility.
Well, Congress turned her down
and to this day it's known
as Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratory.
But what we can say I think is
that science itself can't
be seen as good or evil.
We can only render judgment on
what human that kind makes of it.
Ernest Lawrence says "New paradigm
of scientific research has given us
knowledge about the natural world
that his own contemporaries
could only dream of.
It's given us isotopes
and diagnostic techniques
that save lives.
It put men on the moon.
It's given us new knowledge
about our own biology.
It provides us with waste to battle
disease and it may provide us
with weapons against climate change
even as it's given us the tools
to destroy ourselves too.
And I'd like to leave you with
one last topic to think about
and that's whether after 70
or 80 years we may have
reached the political
and economic limits of big science.
The reason that the Large Hadron
Collider is the biggest accelerator
in the world is that the United
States abandoned its own parallel
project, the super conducting,
super collider in the 1990s mostly
because its budget
had grown so huge,
but also because the scientific
community itself was not united
behind it.
Almost since the beginning, the cost
of big science has
prompted its critics
to ask whether it can get too
expensive, whether it leads us
to value, monumental scientific
efforts more than programs
that might have a direct
relevance to our daily lives
like ending poverty or hunger.
Big science has helped
make our universities great
but it's also helped turn our
professors into administrators,
housekeepers and publicists all
for the cause of raising more money
to make science even bigger.
And part of that, I think it's
the political fear it inspires
because some politicians including
many in congress today recognize
that left alone big science
can yield discoveries
that change the world
and that, of course,
is always a threat
to in trans interest.
Now that said one thing I think
we can be confident about is
that the human thirst for
knowledge is never quenched.
And that if-- and if we want
to an illustration of that,
just consider the excitement
felt a year ago.
Not only among astronomers
and cosmologist
but among the general public about
the extraordinary photos of Pluto
that came from the new horizon
space graph after a nine year voyage
to the absolute limits
of our solar system,
findings that are already
changing scientist understanding
of the life arc of planets.
So yes, Laurence's genius gave us
new access to knowledge but as true
with almost every that
gain came at a cause.
He helped us to learn a lot
but he also gave us a
lot more to think about.
And with that with his image and
Laurence himself overlooking the lab
that he built in a ravine above
the Berkeley campus, I'll thank you
for listening and throw in
the floor for questions.
[ Applause ]
OK. Again, if you want to ask
some questions we have microphones
up here at the front in both aisles.
So let it rip.
>> Shall we start?
After the war Heisenberg, some
with controversially claimed
that he had deliberately made
a mistake in the payload needed
for the weapon in order to slow
down the German atomic bomb project
that he didn't want Hitler to have.
Obviously there's a
self-serving aspect to that.
Do you think there's
any merit to it as well?
>> Michael Hiltzik: Well, you
know, I'm not actually sure
that Heisenberg made that claim
whether it was made on his behalf.
But it's clear if you're familiar
with the so-called
Farm Hall Transcripts.
Farm Hall was a farm house in
the UK where a German physicist
that he says would stay behind
we're rounded up after the war
by the allies and they were shipped
to this form and put together
and they were allowed to communicate
with each and meet and socialize
and every word they
uttered was bogged.
And it was clear from those
conversations and it's clear
from those transcripts that
these scientists were absolutely
flabbergasted when the word came
over that the bomb
existed and it was dropped.
They were not prepared
for this having happened.
It's-- it really looks
from the transcripts
that they had a lot
of disagreements.
They were blaming each other for
who made the mistakes that led
to their failure but it really
does look like it was not so much
of deliberate mistake
as a misconception
about the essential
physics of atomic bombs.
So, yeah, I think that Heisenberg
or his patrons wanted to make hero
out of him or make
him look more heroic
but I think there is
reason to doubt that story.
>> Thank you.
>> OK. You said that before
the atomic bomb was dropped
on Hiroshima there was a
debate among the physicists
about whether the bomb should be
dropped as a demonstration on an--
on populated island, and the fear
was that they might drop a dot.
Why was that that there
was no concern
about them dropping
a dot on Hiroshima?
>> Michael Hiltzik: Well I
think if you're dropping a--
I mean, the idea was that a dot
was going to be bad if it failed
to shorten the war
in a demonstration,
but if you're dropping the bomb
in warfare you're, you know,
you're basically in for
a penny, in for a pound.
There was concern that
it would be that if--
just to go into a little bit more
detail than you may be asking for,
the bomb that was dropped down
in Hiroshima was a one off bomb.
It was a simple bomb because
of the qualities of uranium
that didn't really think
it was going to be a dude
but they never tested
it because the engineers
who built it thought it
was basically a trivial
engineering device.
It was the plutonium bomb
that was tested in trinity
because that was a new technology,
nobody was sure it would work.
But I think the idea was they
didn't really think it would a dude
but the consequences of that fissile
they thought would much worst
than if the goal was to shock the
Japanese regime into ending the war.
Then, since they only have the one
uranium bomb, they needed to use it
in a way that it might work.
>> Hi. I have two parts
of my question.
One, during the time the bomb
was made, were we really worried
about Germany making atomic
bomb, but why did we not worry
about Japan making atomic bomb?
And the other part is, if we used
bomb, the atomic bomb in Germany,
could we be benefited the cold war?
>> Michael Hiltzik: Well the
question is, if we're worried
about Germany making the bomb why
were we not equivalently worried
about Japan?
Is that the question?
>> Yeah.
>> Michael Hiltzik: I think
the conception of Japanese
as enemies was quite a bit different
from the conception of Germany.
In part because we
had so many scientists
in other people other figures
here in the US and then the UK
who had direct experience
with the Nazi regime
and they saw it as
uniquely fearsome.
I don't think there was
quite as much concern
that Japan was banned
on world domination.
They would certainly concern that
it was bent on regional domination.
And it was-- and it was
not as much of a fear
that Japan had the understanding
or the technology that was resident
over in Germany still, even after
all these physicists had left.
So there's very different attitude.
I don't think the Japanese
were nearly as feared in terms
of their ambitions as the Germans.
>> I wonder if you could talk just
a little bit about the current state
of funding for science that I've
read that there's less money
for basics science and
more aimed at science
that can assist corporate products,
corporate technology,
industrial technology.
>> Michael Hiltzik: Sure.
I think there's good reason to
be concerned at what's happened
to scientific funding
especially in the US
over recent years,
really recent decades.
The government, which
had become a major patron
of basic scientific research
after the war and well
into the postwar period has
been withdrawing essentially,
it's been stepping back
from this sort of funding.
In part, because of
political pressure but also
because of budgetary
concern, you know,
essentially conservative
budget making.
Now, I think that's got
two affects that scientism
and we all really should
be concerned about.
One is that basic science is facing
in many ways the starvation budget
and that should be a concern because
this is our seed corn after all.
You don't get applied science.
You don't get advance technology
until you start with basic science
and you pursue it in a way
that follows its own logic.
You can't direct basic science
to happen within a timeframe.
You can't direct basic
science to its specific goal.
You have to let it go
where it leads you.
Now, as the government has stepped
back, its role has been taken
over more and more by industry.
Now, in some ways that's good
because industry has a lot of money
but in many ways it's bad because
industry is simply not inclined
to invest in basic science because
it can't see an immediate payoff
and that's understandable but that's
why we have government funding
of projects like this.
Now in previous books, I've written
about the birth of the internet
and the construction of Hoover Dam.
These were all projects that were
undertaken in their early stages
by government agencies
because private industry
couldn't see an immediate payoff
or a direct payoff for itself
so it wouldn't pursue
this work on its own.
And that's what we're going to see
as industry takes on the funding
of scientific research
more and more.
It's going to become
more inner-directed.
It's going to become more
directed at the core business lines
of those industries and
we're going to give up.
We're going to lose a lot
of research opportunities
that we would have if we really were
still supporting basic research,
not only to the degree
we have in the past
but to an even greater degree.
So as I said, I think we should all
be very concerned about this trend.
We should be concern about the
political attack on basic science
and the misunderstanding and
maybe deliberate misunderstanding
that we get on Capitol Hill
about the value of this work and,
you know, we should hope that
we can reverse that trend.
Oh, I'm sorry, over here.
>> OK. Oh, my question is, you
know, very short and simple
but then I'll give some background
and what I can remember just
so that I'm sure, you know,
this country is so great
and so is the scientist--
science community.
But in between, I see a lot of
dragging around and, you know,
a lot of unnecessarily
suffering that people are going
through especially
decent people like myself.
So, for that purpose, do you
think of the science community
or the scientist and the,
you know, because they work
on that true facts,
not about or writing
about imaginary thing
Shakespeare and this and that.
So is-- are they empowered?
I bet they are but just to educate
the masses, are they the most--
are they the all president of the
United States or the president
of the world or, you know,
that kind of council?
Is it still being worked or is it--
or have they already reached
that status or it's a struggle
between the other groups
for example navy, army,
you know, air force this and that?
So the reason I'm saying that
is, some are I think betting
on the power of Noah's arc
or kind of and which is kind
of make sense when
the things keep on.
You know, if the parents are
very nice, the children are from,
you know, different kind of world
or whatever and they rescuable
for food crams and things like that.
It gets so nasty that the
others will think, "Oh,
we got our Noah's arc so,
you know, we got our thing
and let them do whatever they like."
I feel like that sort of thing
is going on on a rampant scale.
So for example in Japan and the
Germany thing, I know there's--
I bet they have finished or
accomplished lot of closure on--
in terms of how their family
died and this and that.
>> Michael Hiltzik: Well--
>> But in terms of like-- for
example the Germans or the Japanese,
I think they're the most
beautiful people, you know?
And now that many generations
have passed down,
are they able to differentiate
for example in sort
of attacking the all good
Germans or the all good Japanese
or the good Americans or the
good Saudis or whatever rather
than saying that, "Oh, these
are, you know, basically this
but they look similar" but
it's because they are Turkish
or they are Iranians and then
they are hybrids and this and that
and then some of them they
get the equal power and--
>> Michael Hiltzik: All right.
I--
>> Yeah, OK.
>> Michael Hiltzik: Yeah.
I think what--
>> So yeah.
So my goal is to-- yeah,
minimize the hurts and the things
that they know, not--
that don't need to go
through when we have all these
beautiful heaven land I should
at this rate.
At this rate, I think nobody
should be suffering and arguing
and feeling a free to
what-- if I see this world,
my bike would be stolen
when I get out of the--
>> Michael Hiltzik: OK.
Yeah. Let me--
>> -- convention hall.
OK, sir. So in other words, how
much power signs community the
scientist have?
>> Michael Hiltzik: All right, let
me just try to, you know, I mean,
what you're getting at is sort
of a permanent tension among all
of these sort of groups and
factors in science and politics.
And I don't think we're ever going
to be able to get away from that
but we really just have to
work our way through it.
And let me take another
question on this side then.
>> Do you have a question to make?
>> He wanted to know,
Michael, what--
could you tell us about
your next project?
>> Michael Hiltzik: Well, my
next project is a departure.
It's going to be a book
about the gilded age,
the original gilded age of 1890s.
And the consequences for America of
the creation of the Great Railroad
as the first great American big
business, so it's a departure
from this book, they're not
necessarily from my previous book.
And I think there's
another question here.
>> Yes.
>> Michael Hiltzik: And this may
be the last one we have time for.
Yeah.
>> So this goes back to you,
the comments you're
making about funding.
I'm curious you're talking about
a little bit of an evolution
from growing our scientists
to the big science.
And now we live in this YouTube
age, blog celebrities, Kickstarter.
How is that affecting, you
know, ground level innovation,
especially in the sciences there
how could it in the future?
>> Michael Hiltzik: Well
that's a good question.
I-- you're right.
There is a trend of
course towards sort
of the entrepreneurial scientist
and funding that comes in new ways.
I think there's also a reason to
be concerned about sort of the--
I guess the commercialization
of early stage science
that we're seeing in places like
Silicon Valley and elsewhere.
We certainly have seen cases where
scientist working on basic science
at publicly funded institutions
end up sort of hiding their work
from colleagues because they can
see some commercial potential in it.
Laurence himself was very
skeptical about patenting even.
And this was a skepticism
that was much more common
in his day than it is now.
He resisted patenting
the cyclotron originally
but he himself had patrons who
said, look, you have to protect,
you have to protect your invention
from commercial exploitation
that you can't control.
So they insisted that he
file a patent and he did.
Reluctantly he didn't
like the process.
He didn't like having to explain
his work through patent examiners
who couldn't understand it.
Later in his career, he was under
pressure to patent the isotopes
that we're coming out of his lab.
He resisted that and
he won that battle.
In part, he won it by default
because the patent examiners
of the day couldn't be convinced
that that the creation of isotopes
which were natural
materials could actually be
that this could be
patentable inventions
but he didn't like the idea.
He didn't like it originally.
He didn't like the encouraging
of that sort of commercialism
and politics into his lab.
But I think this was a tide that he
tried to hide back and he wasn't all
that successful in doing.
So-- And so I think that's it.
If you have more questions
I'm right here and feel free
to come up and say hello.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.